ladies and gentlemen i'm not making this
video because i want to i do want to
but i'm making it because i have to one
of my rules has been violated guys
that rules we are but animals okay and
i'm not about to violate one of my most
sacred rules the rule is this if a
larger youtuber
makes a video about you mentioning you
even with words conjuncted next to each
other that
appear to be like you like if they're
drinking coffee and talking about
godzilla
that means i have to make a long
response video to that
person immediately as long as humanly
possible actually and the bigger
their channel is the longer the response
video is proportional
to how long they mentioned me for
example ladies and gentlemen some
ordinary gamers made a like a seven
second shout out to me i made a nine
minute video about it
netflix they put me in a mini
docu-series for one second
i made a seven minute video about it
okay i have to do it i mean
it's it's the rules and so i try not
i don't even want to do it sometimes but
i have to do it so with that being said
people don't seem to be learning because
it's well known in the influencer space
you know if you don't want
the heat stay out of the kitchen
or something like that uh cody co guys
dropped me
in his recent video and i just thought
to myself
this is a 12 minute video at least but
let's take a look at what he
said stupid the people making these
coins think the average consumer is
but i mean then again people bought elon
sperm after i made fun of it so
and according to another youtuber who uh
does videos about finance and crypto his
name's coffee zilla
safe for mars is definitely a scam it's
a total copy of another coin
called safe mars wow so there it is
ladies and gentlemen that's my big cameo
i know you thought to yourself this
might as well be copyright infringement
the amount he's using your name but uh
yeah this is
cody ko talking about this channel
covering the soja boy
scam where he mentioned safer mars which
was a crypto scam
that i called out a few days ago and
soja boy was being paid for it
didn't disclose it and i know you all of
you said to me hey
if you can't trust sojourn who can you
trust but i told
y'all it was a scam it's being reported
in major press outlets like the kodiko
youtube channel guys very respected
uh press outlet so now it's mainstream
news
youtuber news on snapchat kodiko blasts
crypto influencers
blasts crypto influencers cody cos
slam dunks on crypto influencers and i
told you guys this
days ago okay but the reason i'm
bringing this up
besides my rule is because of the fact
that there's an
update that i have to give you with the
soja boy story that not even kodiko
had seen yet because it just happened
because safer mars which was promoted by
soja boy
has recently disappeared ladies and
gentlemen
if you go to their page it says this
account doesn't exist
so he promoted something and put up a
link to go buy this token
for something that a few days later
doesn't even exist these influencer
scams have gotten
absolutely out of control and we have to
say something about it okay
this is the whole point of the kodiko
video is these influencer scams are out
of control
but there's so many examples it's even
hard to pick from like recently i saw
this
lindsay lohan saying that the ethereum
market is hinting at a bull run for nfts
it's like
who are these people that all of a
sudden become crypto experts overnight
because they signed up with coinbase
it's absolutely ridiculous everyone's
your financial advisor now guys
and so i had an idea put a stop to this
once and for all
using the power of the kodiko shoutout
and also he gave me an idea quite
frankly
which i'm going to explain in a second
but he mentions the fact
that uh you know all these all these
tokens all these coins
they're just kind of doing the same
thing copying each other's code
and just changing like one word it's a
total copy of another coin
called safe mars they just added an r i
i would invest in ours because it's
safer so you're just gonna invest in
safe moon kind of a risk
ours is a lot safer see this got me
thinking ladies and gentlemen
i want to help protect people from
themselves and when i realize that
people keep
throwing dumb money at projects with
things like safe in the name or safer
in the name or moon star anything i
decided
what if i could join the scam to save
people
from being scammed and that's when
safest
galaxy was born ladies and gentlemen
this is my domain i
i picked the safest by definition
and largest possible crypto coin
and i know what you're thinking that's
impossible isn't the universe
the largest you know possible body of
matter
no because i bought safest universe and
redirected it
to safeasgalaxy.com that's right ladies
and gentlemen
uh i anticipated it all all to protect
the consumer you because we all knew
where this was going we had safe moon
then safe mars then safe star then safer
moon than safer star
it was going to safest and i decided to
jump to the front of the line
let's go let's just let's get it over
with dude if
we're playing this game we're all
copying each other's code and just
throwing it
on a different domain name let's do it
as you can see i have a very nice
graphics here
and i'm about to tell you how to buy
this thing okay because i'm trying to
save you guys so first of all
how to buy you got to be a zilla holder
that means you have to subscribe to
coffeezilla
obviously follow elon musk on twitter a
side thing that i didn't even mention
here it's in like the terms of use
you have to like and retweet every
single thing elon musk does
like if he violates an sec order and
tweets about tesla you have to like it
thirdly you have to tell everyone you
know about safest galaxy ten times a day
at least otherwise you're ineligible now
what do you get for doing all of that
nothing absolutely nothing ladies and
gentlemen did you not see
safest in the title i can't what it's
safest because it's actually technically
the only crypto coin that's not crypto
at all it's not even a coin at all it's
the safest largest technically
non-crypto coin because i decided that
maybe you shouldn't be invested in these
things these sketchy
coins that you have no business in
investing in look i say it all the time
isn't crypto risky enough without
getting invested into these
hacky copied uh erc tokens come on guys
we can do better than this
there are a lot of great kryptos out
there you don't need this trash
and if you do need it i have the safest
and
largest coin in the entire world so just
to save you money
i did that for you free absolutely free
but yeah that's uh
basically it safestgalaxy.com or
safestuniverse.com however you want to
get there
be sure to follow all those rules if you
want to participate
and look uh maybe this response video
will finally teach
cody co a lesson and all of these large
youtubers who think they can just
mention me without getting some kind of
a slam dunk a rebuttal
in their face so that's basically it
very cool of cody to mention us
had to get this quick response out there
didn't i did want to but i
i did it because i had to uh so thanks
for watching i appreciate you guys
and i'll see you in the next one
wake up smell the coffee